- I'm just fascinated by people thinking
there's some secret passive potion
that you're gonna make a
million bucks a year doing dick.
(upbeat music)
You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
The only way you're
gonna work 15 hours a day
for 25 years is 'cause it's your hobby.
You don't do anything that much
unless you fucking love it.
To me, that's why I always talk
about being an entrepreneur
before it was cool,
it's 'cause it's what I loved.
It's like if you were to listen to music,
if you love music,
and I said you literally for a living
can listen to music for 15 hours a day
and do extremely well,
I wouldn't sign up for that.
I don't want to listen
to music 15 hours a day
but I'm sure a lot of people would
or play tennis or whatever.
I think that the people
that always succeed
in the long term,
have found that thing,
that thing that they genuinely would do.
I will never retire.
It just will never happen.
I just know it already today.
I may get super old
and I might not be able to schlep around
but I'll go stand in a flea market
and sell some shit.
To me, it's the thing I've,
it's really been interesting
going through this journey,
even for a lot of you.
It's just interesting to analyze yourself
as you evolve as you get older,
as a six to 12 year old
where I had unlimited
freedom to play outside
in the '80s in New Jersey,
more than half the time,
I chose to wash somebody's car,
shovel somebody's snow.
So this is deeply ingrained,
and I think I see it.
I see it in architecture,
I see it in teaching,
I see it in public service,
I see it in parenting.
If you can just find your thing.
Now for me, my thing
also creates financial,
for some people,
if your dream is to teach,
if you want to teach in a public school,
you're not gonna make a
million dollars a year.
So I think right now my fear,
and even this whole project,
is I'm trying to talk a lot
more about self awareness,
not just entrepreneurship
because I think people
are getting caught up
because there's just no
way to be sustainable.
The reason everybody's,
I get almost 10,000 communications a week
about how do I fix my laziness?
And my answer is do something you like.
You're lazy because you're
doing it for the money
and you don't like it.
You just think it's gonna make you money.
And so people are real estate agents
because their neighbor's making money
and people are social media experts
because they read something about me
or they're gonna be a
cryptocurrency trader
or augmented reality this
and everyone's gonna be on VR
and the next thing and the
next thing and the next thing.
And this is why so many people lose.
They chase cash.
And to your point,
hard work is part of the equation.
It's just part of the equation
'cause somebody's gonna outwork you.
People are like, Gary Vee,
I did a, I don't know
if you guys saw this,
I was flying here today
and I got kind of caught up on work,
I was like fuck it, let
me just answer questions,
so I did an Instagram post today,
ask me questions, I started answering,
people are like, yo Gary Vee,
what do I do when my market
gets really competitive
and everybody wants to do the same shit?
I'm like you have to be
better than everyone.
It's so funny to like,
there's a lot of sneaker stores.
You just have to be better.
And so I'm just fascinated
by people thinking there's
some secret passive potion
that you're gonna make a
million bucks a year doing dick.
Doesn't exist.
So you better figure out what you like
because I was so bad at school
because by 9:30 I looked
at the fucking clock
until I got out of there
at three 'cause I hated it.
And so because I lived my
childhood in hating something
and not succeeding out
of the hatred of it,
the fact that 90% of people careers
are the way I did school
and those are longer
and take up a lot more of your life,
that's devastating to me
and we have to change that conversation.
- Any tips to people out there who,
how does a day in the
life of John or Gary look
and how would you recommend
people have more productive days
doing whatever it is,
whether it's something they like or not?
- For me one of the conversations
that I wanted to create clarity
over the last three years is sleep.
I answered that today.
Somebody's like,
a lot of people asked,
how much do you sleep
and my answer's six, seven or eight hours
and it fucks with people
'cause they think I'm
sleeping like an hour.
And my point there is sleep's important.
I don't know who think's
they're gonna survive
without sleep.
Sleep's important.
What's important for what I'm about
is what you're doing when you're awake.
I'm fascinated by people who say I hustle,
I sleep four hours
but then watch three hours
of YouTube videos a day.
And so for me, as you know,
and what you're referring to
as somebody who interacts with me is
Tyler's sending you emails like,
can you do 11:30 PM to 12:30PM?
Like every minute I have is programmed.
- It's like more like 11:15 to 12:25.
- No look, I mean the
amount of five and seven
and 10 and 13,
I basically
Tyler, I see your face, what do you think,
it's eight o'clock until 11PM
is pretty much programmed
to the minute with zero slots for anything
but the next meeting?
- [Tyler] Yeah six AM really.
- But I'm working out, right?
But like for work,
eight to 11 with zero
lunch, zero downtime.
If I go take a piss,
I'm cutting into some meeting.
Now, but here's the
thing, here's the thing,
that's matching my happiness and ambition.
That is not for 99.9% of people,
time management needs to be predicated
on what makes you happy
and what is coming out of your mouth.
The biggest thing I'm worried about
is people are talking big game
but then their actions don't match it.
So to me,
it's happiness first
and then eliminating hypocrisy.
And that's how I think about it.
So for me, it's that
because I love this game,
it's what I would want to do
and my ambitions are great and I enjoy it.
I want to spend nine PM
to 10 PM on a meeting
to build what I'm building.
It's what I love to do.
It's no different than being in the studio
or painting or, it's
just what I love to do.
- I am probably both of
you guys biggest fans
and once you've made it,
what continues to drive
you to do what it is
that you're passionate about?
- I would argue
that if you really knew
everything about me
and you read it all,
every action I ever did,
you would look me in the face and ask me
why do you sabotage yourself
in business and financial environments?
And I would tell you that
deep down subconsciously
I love it so much
that I just want it to happen forever.
And so for me,
making it is a,
that's what blows me away
about somebody who's like
I just need to make a million bucks
and then I'm gonna go to Jamaica.
I don't have that in my head.
I just want to play forever.
And that's why I'm trying to get people
to understand the process.
Because it is very clear to me
that people that are in love
with their craft and process
can win
and that's why I'm trying
to change the conversation
around how much money you need to be happy
because it doesn't work.
Like I just know
unbelievable amounts of data
of how many people have lots of money,
how many people don't have
lots of money by our standards,
and how happy they are
and it doesn't take a lot of money
to be alive in society.
It's about what you spend money on.
And I can't get over this,
I just really wish people
liked what they did
and the internet makes,
where we got caught,
why everybody in this room is caught
is you were parented by people
that didn't have the
luxury of a mature internet
and so there was no practicality
around doing what you love.
It's just not how the world worked.
The internet,
which everybody here including myself
and including the man who
is at the forefront of it
in a lot of ways with what
he did with the iPhone
is grossly underestimated,
like deeply underestimated.
And so I just really want people
to do what they like.
It will work.
They just have to eat
shit for a long time.
People are like, well
Gary, I have debt or this.
I'm like cool,
to live the life that you want,
isn't it a good idea
to punt the next six years,
eat shit, give up,
'cause the game's very simple,
if you've got debt
or have to put a roof over
your head or somebody else
then you work whatever
job is paying you that.
But I'm asking you what are you doing
from six PM to midnight.
And if you have to go build slowly
your portfolio, your Shopify store,
your Instagram account, your
YouTube channel, your content,
wouldn't you be pumped if I told you
for the next four years it's tough
and you don't watch as
much Netflix and sports
and hanging out
but then you get to live happy
for the rest of your life?
Everybody, in theory
would sign up for that.
The reality is a lot of people
don't want to grind for four years.
People don't like pain.
It's why most people don't have six packs.
I mean that,
I mean that.
There's a lot of people here
who want to be in better shape
you just don't want to work out.
You just don't want to eat well.
I lived it for the first
38 years of my life.
And then I got into better shape.
I still hate it.
I fucking was pissed this morning
waking up at 5:55 to work out
but because I want it,
and so I've gone through
doing something that
didn't come natural to me,
that I hate to this day
four and a half years later
but I just want to live 15 years longer.
And so for me, it's like,
if any person in here is unhappy,
I need to know every
single minute you spend
on anything but your job.
Because I'll tell you
taking those leisure hours,
which you're using to
escape your unhappiness,
you're literally watching
Netflix or sports
or playing video games
or listening to music
to escape your reality that
you're not happy about.
I want you to take those hours
and start building something
that gets you off your issue
and it might taken seven years
but it's worth it.
Everybody here is gonna lie
for fucking 60, 70 more years.
People got tricked,
54 is young.
And so people have terrible ability
to put time in perspective
which is why their
behaviors are so broken.
- All right.
Anybody got a six pack out there?
- Show me, show me, show me.
- Six pack, let's see it.
- Let's go.
Let's go.
My guy.
Fuck man, that was more like 10.
- One person has a six pack.
- Pretty sexy out there.
- What is the importance
of investing in the people
and how do you inspire people
who are looking to accomplish their dreams
and how do you keep them going
trying to accomplish your
mission and your dream?
- To me, it's one on one marketing.
What Tyler cares about today
is different than what he
cared about 24 months ago.
DRock cares,
Colin worked for me
and because we had a real relationship,
I helped put him on to
the job he has today
and that's why he's sitting
here supporting me today.
So even when they're out of the system,
it's one big system.
Karma is practical.
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing.
That is actually how humans work.
It's why we're still here.
Humans are inherently phenomenal.
This is what's so fucking me up
about our culture right now.
We're spending so much
time on the negative,
rightfully so,
there's so much political banter,
there's so many people
that are trying to get their fair shake,
there's so much going on,
I don't need to go there.
But what it's done in the micro
is makes everybody look at the negative
instead of realizing
this is the best moment to be alive.
For anybody here who on
skin tone or race or gender
feels suppressed,
talk to your grandmother.
Ask 'em if it's better in 2018 than 1974.
People are confused.
And so like we have a long
way to go everywhere globally
but we lack looking at the truth
and we lack optimism
because most people are
so scared to get tricked,
they'd rather be cynical.
I love when people are like,
yo, Gary Vee, but I keep it real.
I'm like, no, no, you
keep it real negative.
(audience laughs)
You keep it real cynical.
You don't keep it real.
Optimism is a strategy.
I really believe that.
I believe that life is
completely a perspective
and like to me,
I'm solution oriented.
Every day, every day,
my inbox is filled,
my texts are filled,
with shit that cripples people.
And for me,
it's like I signed up for this.
If I want it,
everything's got a cost.
Most people want all these great things,
they're just not willing to pay the piper,
the emotional piper.
That's the shit that fucking sucks.
Everybody wants to be
an Instagram celebrity
but nobody wants anybody
to leave a comment
that they're ugly.
So everything has a price
and perspective really matters.
And so I think that
staying in tune to what,
when you're building an organization,
somebody comes in as a 23 year old,
they want more money.
As a 27 year old,
they want a little more time
because they just found the person
they think they're gonna marry.
Then they have a child.
Then they want money again.
Then they want a title
because the kid they came in with
is now ahead of them two slots
but that kid worked 15 hours a day
and didn't do a relationship
and it becomes this whole thing.
But you've got to keep listening.
And that's what I heard from you right now
and that is huge.
If you're trying to
build something, listen.
That's where it comes from.
I talk a whole lot.
It confuses people.
I'm spending almost all my time listening.
That's why I read every fucking comment.
That's me listening.
Every time you don't see
my posting or on live,
unless I'm in a business meeting,
I'm reading your comments.
That's how I'm figuring out
what the next piece of content's gonna be.
And so I'm just shocked
in watching so many
people here want to win
and they're not replying to comments,
they're not listening.
It's so selfish.
It's a mistake.
And that's what every
company and boss does.
It's selfish,
and they think, I love that you said that,
they throw money at shit
or dangle the potential of money,
just trying to milk you
for another six months.
One of the things that
I've really been thinking
a lot about this year
is how many times people
stop me in an airport
or an event like this or what have you
and they freak out
and they're people of the industry.
Especially fancier events
where there's cooler people,
a lot of people will,
I'm just being real, I mean this,
really VIP events,
there's inevitably
somebody who will freak out
and they'll be like I never freak out
and what they're basically saying to me is
I've met way more famous people than you
and there was no reaction.
Why am I getting emotional
or why do I want to take
this selfie with you?
And I'm like listening right.
So this is happening and happening,
of course for like my ego
and all that it's awesome
but I'm interested.
So I'm thinking.
And then I'm like finally
it just made a lot of sense.
It's like look you could,
listen, I love the weekend and future
as much as anybody else
but like an artist that
puts out good music,
outside of like a singular
song that changed your life,
it's just good music.
Whereas somebody who's putting out content
that's desperately desperately trying
for your life to be better
and wants nothing in return,
you're gonna have a different reaction
when you meet that person
than if somebody can
drop 54 points a night.
It's just different.
- [Female] Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome.
And I think that long winded humble brag
is positioned for one reason,
you need to figure out
how to bring so much value
that whatever you're trying to accomplish
just naturally happens
because you built so
much leverage by giving.
This is why I get mad
when you don't reply to the eight people
that do leave a comment for
you on your social media.
You're trying to get bigger
and you don't have time
for the eight people
that actually care about you right now.
Listen, you're holding it,
that book, the Thank You Economy,
that's the one for me
and I say it all the time,
it's the one that sold the least
and it's the one that means the most to me
because I'm a product tonight
of somebody who from 2007 to 2011
went to sleep at four AM
because I would not go to sleep
until every tweet directed at me
got responded to.
Now the math is won
and I've kind of,
I'm not gonna win that game,
but like most of you who have ambitions
can still and you don't
and I'm really trying to put
pressure on that conversation.
11 fans become 22
if you actually give a fuck about those 11
and nobody does.
They take it for granted.
They do a collab with a great brand,
they put their name on it,
they think one photoshoot
and one fucking appearance
at the biggest retail store they can go to
is gonna sell it
and it's just we have too many options,
we have too many options.
- And so one of the things on
the shoes is being positive
and so how has positivity
impacted your business?
- I mean any entrepreneur
that's successful
has to rely on positivity
because it's not rational.
The segway conversation
from we're selling sneakers
here at this flea market
to we're gonna have 3,000 employees
and all these stores
is not a rational one.
It's why students and
entrepreneurs are so different.
It doesn't play out on an Excel sheet.
And so for me positivity
is my natural DNA,
it's the environment my mother created,
but it is an entrepreneurial one.
I remembered something that
really kind of struck me,
which is the car washing,
90 people said no, four said yes.
But it took me 30 years to
remember that people said no.
And so like when you are this
you're only focused on the
yeses or the positivity.
It's a net gain.
The amount of mistakes you
guys have made is ludicrous.
It's just you don't think about them
when you're making progress.
That I hate more than cynicism.
Because you're making
judgment without full context.
So people that are positive
versus people that are negative
are completely exposed every day
because we're making,
one of the things that I'm trying
to talk a lot more about
lately is judgment.
Everyone's just in full judgment mode
because everyone's got social
and they can add their two cents
and nobody knows shit.
People are always like Gary Vee,
why can you handle so much criticism?
I'm like 'cause they don't know me.
They have no idea what's happening
in my bedroom and my bank
account and my tax returns
and my private meetings.
How could I possibly take any weight?
I only care about what people,
I care about what you think about me
because you know me.
I care about what Colin thinks about me.
He knows me.
That's what I care about.
I can't care about SallyPants63, right?
Because what's happening now
is we're exposing ourselves.
SallyPants63 saying I suck shit,
that means her life sucks.
If you have time to
leave negative comments
on somebody else's social media,
your life is not in a good place.
It's the quickest tell.
I have no time to do that
'cause my life is good,
I'm busy, I'm doing shit.
I have no time to consume your video
and decide you're a dork.
It's ludicrous.
I think a lot of people right now
think that technology's changing us
and I think it's exposing us
which is why we're going
through a lot of heat right now
which I'm excited about.
It's one step backwards,
two steps forward
and I'm excited that we're finally,
especially in America,
facing a lot of its shortcomings
and I do think over 100 year window,
this will be looked back at
the moment where a lot of
good happened to our society
because we had to face so
many of our true shortcomings
that we didn't want to face
and they've been hidden
my mainstream media.
So it hurts,
a lot of us have to deal with shit
that maybe we don't want to
but I promise you,
watch how, remember when you're
super duper old, this combo,
we are headed in the right direction.
We're just gonna have
to deal with some shit
over the next 10, 15 years
to reconcile the shit we've
been hiding conveniently
through mainstream media.
(upbeat music)